-Our first guest tonight is a
Tony and Academy Award-winning
actress you know from movies
such as "Chicago," "Traffic,"
and the Netflix series
"Wednesday."
She stars in "National Treasure:
Edge of History,"
which beings streaming
with a two-episode premier
December 14th on Disney+.
Let's take a look.
-Finding anything you like?
♪♪
-You're Billie?
-Who were you expecting?
-I don't know.
But I didn't expect someone who
looks like
they walked out of the town
in "Big Little Lies."
-This isn't a television show.
Where's the relic?
-Where's Oren?
[ Door opens ]
♪♪
Oren.
-I've kept my side
of the bargain.
Now, where's the relic?
-Please welcome back to the
show Catherine Zeta-Jones!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Catherine.
-It's always lovely to see you,
Seth.
-You're very villainous
in that clip.
-I'm a mean girl.
-Yes.
Do you enjoy a little villainy?
-Oh, I so loved it.
-Yes.
It seems it comes to you
very naturally.
-Well, yeah.
No, it doesn't.
I'm actually a nice Welsh girl,
but I put that blond wig on.
-Yes, I have a photo, 'cause the
blonde --
Was this --
Did you get to have a hand
in the choosing of the wig?
-I did, yeah.
I wanted something different.
After coming off Morticia,
I thought let's do blonde,
and I wanted to know
if blondes have more fun.
-And did you have a good time?
-I had a great time.
-That's wonderful.
This is a spinoff series
based on
the "National Treasure" films.
-Yes.
-And it's obviously
much like those films --
a great deal about history,
about investigating.
Were you a good student
growing up?
-I was a conscientious student,
but I spent half my time
in the theater,
so I had to go back
and, like, play catch-up.
But history,
of all the subjects,
was literally my favorite.
And my kids are both --
my son's graduated.
He's just finished -- graduated
with history at college.
-That's wonderful.
-And my daughter's doing it.
So we come from
a history-loving family.
So this show
is right up my alley.
-Were they fans of the original?
Are they the age
where they watched
the original
"National Treasure" films?
-Well, they were babes in arms
when the originals came out,
and I loved them.
When Jerry Bruckheimer called me
up to do part of it,
I was like, "Well,
who am I gonna play?"
I remember Nic Cage,
Harvey Keitel, Justin Bartha,
but they told me there was this
new character.
And I long-windedly
told my kids about,
"When you were babes in arms,
there was these two films,
and they were fabulous.
It was all about history
and this treasure hunt."
They went, "Whoa, whoa,
are you talking about
'National Treasure'?"
And I went, "You know it?"
They went like,
"Yes, we love it."
So it was just great.
I didn't -- I didn't realize
that, you know,
they had such great legs,
that franchise.
-Yeah.
-So it lends itself
to a great 10-part
series on Disney+,
because unlike the film,
as great as they were,
is that 90-minute capsule.
We got time to really --
I'm going to say something.
I'm not mean all the time.
-No.
-I mean, you do wonder why this
woman wants this relic so bad.
What is the --
-Seems like you've fallen
in love with this villain
character you're playing.
-I did.
-You're out here defending her.
-But I played a few. Look.
People forget -- In "Chicago,"
I was a double murderess,
and in "Traffic"
I was a drug dealer
who completely did the whole --
-Yeah, why are we letting you
off the look?
-Yeah!
Why is everyone to surprised?
-Your son came with you
the premiere.
Do you feel like a cool mom
when you get your handsome son
to be on your arm?
-I do, and we bought him
that suit in London.
-Did you?
-Yeah.
It's his first kind of London --
He said, "You look like you're
out of the 'Dead Poets Society.'
Is that a good thing, Mum?
Is that a good thing?"
I went, "Yeah."
But you know what, he's --
he was in school for four years,
so he gets the chance now
to come along
because Michael's working.
I just -- It's the gift
that keeps on giving, Seth.
I don't know what to say.
-You and Michael Douglas,
22 years married,
congratulations.
That's an accomplishment.
-I know.
Can you imagine 22 years?
-Yeah.
-We had -- Yeah,
and we have the same birthday.
-Oh, that's wonderful.
-We have like September 25th
is our same --
25 years difference.
-Yeah, okay.
Not the same birthday.
-Not the same day.
But -- And so we have
September 25th is our birthday
and then November 18th
is our anniversary.
So we went off to Morocco.
-That's very --
-Fabulous, actually, yeah.
-Do you -- Historically,
do your kids...
Have you introduced them
to your work, you and Michael?
Are they fans?
Or is it weird for them
because you're their parents?
-They've seen some.
And they say that they've seen
everything, but they haven't.
I get it, you know?
And I'm okay with that.
I haven't seen everything
I've done either.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you know --
When you're making one, do you
ever think to yourself,
"I'm probably never
going to see this"?
-No, it's not like that.
[ Laughter ]
No!
I actually -- I'm way too
critical and analytical.
And it's -- you know, I'm --
-I agree. I don't love
watching myself either.
-Every now and again something
comes on TV and I go,
"Oh, I think I'm -- I'm in that"
and I watch it.
But my kids want to be actors,
even though they're --
I was convinced they were going
to be history teachers.
And so they love
the craft of acting,
and they get our business,
you know.
-Yeah.
-Which, my gosh,
this business
has been great to me.
I've had a really
wonderful life thus far.
-Well, there you go.
I have a lot more to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from Catherine Zeta-Jones.